you can tell a lot about a country from
its passport color is the first give
away nations tend to pick colors that
reflect their national character New
Zealand decorates its famous rugby team
its airline and its passports in the
nation's favorite color black many
Islamic countries to have green
passports because of the importance of
the color in the Muslim faith but as
well as a statement of national identity
color can demonstrate international
cooperation
the British passport was originally a
regal navy blue but after Britain joined
the European Union in 1973 it switched
to burgundy red in line with other EU
countries the common color was supposed
to make European passports instantly
recognizable but since colors can't be
patented nothing stops others with the
same idea a number of countries that
aspire to join the EU have changed their
passports to burgundy - meanwhile
Britain has decided to leave the club
it's government has announced that the
UK passport will revert back to navy
blue after brexit if you have a passport
from Singapore or South Korea you are in
possession of one of the most powerful
travel documents on earth
passport power is measured by the number
of countries the holder can access
visa-free currently sharing first place
in the power rankings Singaporean and
South Korean passports provide visa-free
access to 162 countries each British
passport holders share fourth place in
the power ranking with six other nations
each accessing 159 countries visa-free
Americans ranked fifth with access to
158 Somalia Syria Pakistan and Iraq are
among the world's least powerful
passports Afghanistan is the lowest
ranking of all with visa-free access to
just 26 countries having to get a visa
is a hassle first there is the
never-ending forum then there are
lengthy appointments and expensive fees
some visas also require travelers to pre
booked flights to prove that they intend
to return home but there are unexpected
upsides to some of the world's weaker
passports middle-ranking olivia is one
of just a handful of countries whose
citizens can enter Angola visa-free
India is one of only three countries
whose citizens have visa-free access
interview time
hello ranking passwords limits your
choices but not your sense of adventure
[Music]
you